doing makeup for people it's a way for
me to demonstrate that they can feel
powerful that they can feel beautiful
it's the same message in Buddhism I'm
just encouraging people so that they
feel like they are worthy I am koto
Nishimura
I am a Buddhist monk and also a makeup
artist I have been a makeup artist for
around nine years as a makeup artist I
have done makeup for Christina Milian
Halima Aydin and I also helped miss USA
I was born in a temple in Tokyo and both
of my parents are monks but I was not
interested in Buddhism at all when I was
young I didn't want to be a mom when I
was in high school I was scared of
people figuring out my sexuality so I
always hid my personality I thought
people will disagree me
[Music]
so so I chose a university in New York
in a different environment I had a hope
that maybe I can be myself when I was in
New York I felt very encouraged I felt
being gay it's nothing a barrier so why
hide I started to play with makeup and I
was so amazed it was like going to world
of color for me to explore I was very
hopeful so that's when I started to want
to learn more I learned about a makeup
artist who did makeup for Miss Universe
Japan and I became her assistant I was
always hoping that I can make more
people be proud to be who they are but
after my university I started to think
what is my roots I decided to come back
to Japan and to join the Hmong training
training to become a monk I actually was
really really hard I consulted with the
master and he told me that the most
important role of Buddhism is to tell
people that everybody is equal and I
felt that this message can save me and
more people so it's my mission to let
people know that they can be who they
are
uniqueness is OK and you can
celebrate so I teach makeup my favorite
one is LGBTQ friendly makeup seminars
makeup is a great way to help people
feel beautiful and hopeful I think all
religion came from also wanting to help
people
I want people to feel that they are
equal they are powerful they can be who
they are and be proud
you
[Music]